this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon and welcome to a
sweltering well slightly warm sabi sands
private game reserve in the beautiful
South Africa my name is Brenda Smith I
have dangerous dev the dimpled dish on
camera hiding under his big Sun Hat why
I have no idea
remember if you want to ask us any
questions hashtag Safari live on Twitter
or just pop your questions into your
YouTube stream now my morning didn't go
quite as but I would have liked it
everything I was looking for Beatle Dorf
out of our Traverse area so I don't
actually have a plan for this afternoon
I'm just going to bumble about and rely
on my charm and good luck
maybe I'll have some luck with some
leopards the Lions unfortunately are
still inside Torchwood and I don't think
they're going to be coming out rightly
they caught a young hippo yesterday or
this morning I'm not sure I'll find out
more details a little bit later but
we're gonna head to the west no one's
really been checking the western
sections for a while maybe dulu is
around because they didn't find her in
the West this morning the hawk Maury is
far away Gianni is far away but James is
sitting with some spotted creatures far
north in the Maasai Mara however they're
not a cat why does he speak with such
muted tones well the answer is because
there is a company here at the hyena den
of the North clan and they are filming
and we're I to use my normal exuberant
tones I have no doubt I would completely
ruin the documentary that they're making
good afternoon my name is James Henry
and on camera today very nervous we have
got to Bungay because he is making his
television debut this evening please do
talk to us using the hashtag so I live
on Twitter now and of course the YouTube
chat stream if you'd like to you to
assume now what we had here yesterday
evening was very interesting we were at
the North clan den for a long time and
we had our TV rehearsal here and that
hyena there it was either that one woods
companion that you and I followed during
the course of the show yesterday and
then we went off air we thought we were
sitting with the same high no he'd been
following we had to at the den exactly
where that one is there one of them
walked off we assumed it was the same
one that had been there the whole time
that
remained turns out it wasn't turns out
there is a brand new tiny little cub in
the hole that that hyena is sitting
above and it was so new that it could
barely walk and it was so new that it
actually left quite a lot of moisture on
the sand when she pulled it out and I
wondered if it wasn't actually very
recently born in other words sort of a
few hours old maybe even perhaps even
less so that's quite interesting we had
a wonderful time here last night so
we're gonna sit and wait and see what
happens here we have not managed to find
any further hyenas here at this den as
we didn't yesterday but I am told by the
inimitable hyena researchers of the
University of oh gosh I forgot it it's
not a Minnesota Wisconsin is it
Wisconsin well this is terrible
someone will remind me shortly anyway
wonderful Heiner researchers and they
tell me that
waffles was here as was Anna earlier
today so with any luck we will see both
of those I'm gonna stay a little bit
away from that film vehicle for now
because I don't want to ruin their
documentary right like I say shouting
and holding forth as it were while they
are trying to get soft cooing x' and
squid rings michigan state there he goes
michigan state university thank you um
car thank you very much
they do an absolutely fantastic job of
hyena research here and without them the
north clan hierarchy and it's mashed
nations would have been extremely
extremely difficult for us to unpack
it's an extremely long running program
they've had here and they've got a
number of dedicated researchers who've
been very good to us
so we're going to stay here and see if
another high-end or two doesn't pop its
head a part of this interesting thickets
now I was thinking to myself oh hello I
wonder if she's looking with the sort of
desire towards the film vehicle maybe
they've got something tasty in there
that they've just opened up to eat or
maybe there's something behind us
apparently there were two male lions
here this morning two young male lions I
think the same males that we had
yesterday evening verse nice you hurt my
heart you say is this really live that's
nice
yes it is live no one is lying to you no
one is trying to pull the proverbial
wool over your eyes I know in these
times of fake facts fake news and all
sorts of fakeness around the world it's
very difficult to find any form of
authenticity but you have just stumbled
upon some you've just stumbled upon a
live stream of authenticity taking place
right now welcome to the Safari it's
lovely to have you with us and I'm going
to dedicate the next 30 seconds of the
Safari purely to you
that must be about 30 seconds let's go
back to the Heine just getting a little
bit awkward but yes it is entirely live
from the Maasai Mara in Kenya where I'm
sitting now at this beautiful high in a
den and of course the Western Kruger
National Park of sunny magical South
Africa now I think this is the mother of
the little one but I could be wrong
there were two cubs in the den one
slightly older of about eight weeks and
the other brand-new now if a lion was to
come across this den the adult would
simply abandon it I'll come back later
oh hang on a second
it's just let's just wait and see what
happens here I know that Kirsten who's
directing has told me to go back to the
real hi-hi Universe whisperer
who's Jamie Patterson but Jamie doesn't
actually have anything at the moment
Kirsten do you mind very much if we stay
here just a few minutes I know you'd
rather hear Jamie's silky turns while
she drives a car but there might be
something quite interesting going on
here I can't see anything behind us that
looks to me like a startled hyena like
she's seen or smelt a predator coming
this way and that could only mean a lion
or a vast clan of invading hyenas oh to
be exceptionally unusual this is the
natal or Maine den of the North clan
just watch her carefully and see where
she goes I'm still trying to figure out
who this is if anybody's got any idea
I'd love to know youngish female
Merritt's hyenas do live in clans but
they don't always forage together for
example this clan is about 60 strong and
you will seldom see 60 hyenas together
unless they are hunting something very
big or unless there are in a clan war
and we've certainly captured some
footage Jaime has been around them when
they've had a big boxing match with the
happy zebra clan and then there were
probably 30 members of the clan facing
off 30 members of the happy zebras but
they do forage alone quite a lot the
obviously stay at the den alone from
time to time I would expect the my jock
to come back and feed her cubs here at
some stage so we can hang around but in
South Africa where the real high in a
whisper is apparently you will
definitely find that the hyenas do a lot
more single solitary foraging than they
do here even that's because the clans
are that much smaller you did this quite
a lot yesterday you know walking away
from the den and then coming back if
it's the same one
she is quite young I don't think she's
more than three I don't know where that
puts her in the hierarchy of the North
clan but I'm gonna go with mid ranked
somewhere mid ranked
going straight back to the den smelt
something I think maybe some lions way
in the distance you don't see any of the
hyenas here alright apparently we have
had enough of this actual hyena and
we're going to go now across to the
hyena whisperer hello hello in a very
good afternoon my name is Jaime the
hyena whisperer and this morning no this
afternoon is Senzo on camera with me is
my great pleasure to have his company
once again we did so much whispering to
the hyenas this morning that we had the
most magical sighting of the Juma plan
here on Juma you know and we even had a
hyena grooming himself right next to the
vehicle it was beautiful it was truly a
display of a hyena spinal flexibility
remember you can get hold of us on
hashtag safari live on twitter
alternatively you can contact us in the
youtube comments section I've to tell
you a funny story about this whole hyena
thing people in the mara keeps sending
me pictures of hyenas and going who is
this not all people not just random
people off the street but you know wild
earth people but they'll send me a
picture of just perfect ears or the
briefest flash of this portion the front
portion of the shoulder
who is this I don't know I can't tell
from that is 80 plus members of the clan
some of them have very similar spots on
their one portion of the shoulder anyway
enough about hyenas for now because it's
far too hot for me to go to the hyena
den on Juma I've got a distinctly
concerned feeling that tonight for the
SABC show there they're going to be
no-shows but we'll wait and see I'm
going to try and help bring tarts in the
meantime we tracked and gone off a Juma
this morning so now we're looking for
way tracked Andy off this morning we're
now looking for teen Garner
he's gonna be here somewhere I assume we
haven't heard him calling and we haven't
heard him we haven't seen him with
husana which makes me think he's on his
own kill somewhere around here so that's
my thinking so I'm gonna try and give
brains a hand for his so utterly
despondent about his prospects for today
I know that feeling that he can use his
charm and exceedingly nice personality a
very good afternoon - goo goo I'm sorry
I have imagined something I have
imagined it goo would like to know if I
know the long-term purpose of the Mara
hyena projects there isn't actually one
so there's no specific end goal it's a
constant learning about the hyenas over
multiple generations and a malted period
of time longest predator project I think
in Africa if not the world's very very
long-running predator project so there's
no set goal there are multiple students
at any one point in time doing multiple
research into multiple aspects of hyenas
lives so whether it's their problem
solving or their hormone levels or their
stress levels like a hormone level
stress level same sort of difference
their social dynamics the evolution
whether or not hyenas in close proximity
to humans have a different behavioural
set than hyenas that are further away
and have no interaction with humans
apart from the odd safari vehicle so
there's there's lots of different
projects that they carry out there and
all of them for different reasons but
all equally important because obviously
the more you understand about hyenas the
more we can conserve them and at the
same time it's not just about that it's
also learning about ourselves as well
there's a lot of parallels between hyena
social dynamics and primate social
dynamics
so it's really accepted in the case of
hyenas the apex predator kind of like
humans or one of the apex predators
though there's actually there's lots of
different reasons why those studies are
being carried out there are truly
intriguing I think it would be a very
good idea if you wanted to go and have a
look at some of their blog posts I mean
I'm not being paid to punt them so I can
they've helped us out immensely if you
want to go look at their blog blog posts
or if you want to go and have a look at
some of the research papers
dr. whole camp is the foremost expert on
hyenas or one of the foremost experts on
hyenas fascinating stuff we've learnt a
vast amount just in the past few years
about hyena behavior that's turned on
understanding of them on its head
alrighty I'm searching for well I think
I'm searching foot in Ghana Torino why I
think that I am let's go across to
Sydney who at least knows exactly what
he's searching for a very very good
afternoon and welcome to the beginning
of the show I am Sydney boomerang my
cozy and I'm travelling with Sebastian
who is my camera operator this afternoon
our plan is quite very easy we are
looking for a spotted cat specifically
Osan and for incase if we need our
attention you can follow us on twitter
hashtag safari live you can also follow
us on youtube chat stream the Sun is
very hot at the moment so this cat is no
longer in the drainage we left him here
this morning so I'm just now trying to
check around this drainage line to see
if we can find him here maybe he is
somewhere under this bushes here
[Applause]
if I am on a very difficult so now let's
go to James who is already having a
hyena well we're still here trying to
identify this I think I've got slightly
closer to figuring it out I think
looking at one of a few obviously
Anatolian quite possibly perhaps LC just
looking at the spots there and looking
at photographs now LC oh I had another
theory and my theory was that it that
hyena is flawless the picture on that
side is wrong oh is it so difficult to
tell
might be might be flawless after all
this is a male kiss definitely not
flawless that's pathetic
I'm dreadful at this everyone I'll get
better I promise I'll do my level best
to get better Jamie says anna has a
horseshoe on her bottom that's very kind
thank you Jamie
now if the great hyena whisperer could
perhaps prevail upon the hyena to show
us its bottom that would be extremely
helpful
yeah I'm afraid my capabilities do not
extend figuring this one out
we've sent Jamie a picture maybe she'll
be able to figure it out I don't think
that hyenas older than four which should
give us an idea I mean I'm looking at
these identicals but my gosh it's all
just kind of blaring into one for some
did my poor recognition techniques and
skills barely recognize myself in the
mirror let alone the individuals in a
clan of sixty hyenas
hmm yes cassia I think Kathy I think
you'll find that strapped ina habits are
very different from the spotted hyena
habits spotted hyenas are unique in the
hyena family which of course is a family
or on its own and that is because they
are the only ones that have this kind of
matriarchal society where the females
dominate the males and where they live
in client's now as far as I'm aware a
striped hyenas much like brown hyenas
live solitary lives I will just check
that up for you but I'm pretty sure they
lived in solitary lives much drier areas
than this and you'll find that the drier
the area the more solitary the animals
tend to be and this of course you happen
to be a sociable Weaver in which case
you live in a great big friendly party
group let me just check for you I'm
pretty sure that what I've told you is
accurate I would hate to tell you a lie
especially on Sundays lying on Sundays
just no good striped hyena tall and
slender yes yes yes Chris runs from
tails they scrub dry savannas urban
habitats rubbish common behavior depends
on whether or not spotted hyenas present
where the two species coexist strapped
is quieter more retiring perhaps salt
more solitary and cryptic but yes they
are solitary
I'm just doing me a big striped hyena
can weigh pretty much the same as a
smallish spotted hyena be cool I'm just
reading that's a spotted hyena and
you've we knew about that so all the
others are almost entirely solitary
fiume you've made a very hilarious joke
that goes as follows this hyenas name is
Xena when you see her you must say hi
ena very good that's not a hyena in the
background that is a tipple sketchy
means returned my identity now that she
stood up tipples good I wish that tipple
scourge would try and find us some
further hiders because i need some
further hyenas for the television show
this evening one how you ness not forget
to do mystery brings out her baby then
she'll do just nicely I'm hoping quite
desperately that the film crew in front
of us is not in enabled with night
division like we are and all therefore
have to vacate the area relatively soon
I've lost my identity - where was it -
come on now
characters hyenas yes No - North clan
yeah well alright so let's just look on
the side there she's got a bit of a
stripe going down sort of obvious
dotting if you like down the side one
big blob above it I'm sure none of you
know what on earth I'm talking about
could that be an it that's not an
Italian it's not an ax
I don't think of course this thing has
arranged such that you have to scroll
through everything you can't scroll
through just the adults and just the
females
it still looks most like flawless but if
lost flawless as a male then ain't no
male once got baby I suppose there's two
very pronounced dots there on the
shoulder are quite distinctive let's try
and see if I can find those yeah there
we go
it is an ax it's definitely an Italian
she's the only one with those two very
pronounced dots
hooray we've got it okay so she's older
then three years he's actually six I'm
pretty sure that that's who we looking
at those two distinct dos there are a
pretty obvious good okay we've got
anatolian she's got a new youngster
don't know where she fits in the
hierarchy we'll figure it out now let's
get Leo Smith he was looking I think for
something using his charm and good looks
Oh James James James yes sir we are
looking I think what we gonna do
it's Sydney's going to check the last
position of us on earth if he has no
luck then I'll go try give him a hand in
that area maybe go first the walkie I
think the Sun is gonna be quite fast
somewhere and the other problem is that
he's not likely to go towards Galago pan
or or or the via Telepan because after
that little rain and special Azure
drainage systems there there's a few
secret spots with it some rocks it might
still be holding a bit of water so he
doesn't have to move too far now
speaking of the sauna I noticed on might
have been total Facebook one of those
thing in my Bob's that there was a lot
of discussion that husana might be ill
from eating these in yalla he is not ill
he is just very fat and very lazy the
tannins in them in the stomach of the of
the the the animals he's eating is not
going to affect him he's got a
completely different digestive system so
please don't worry her sauna is not sick
he is fine I understand you guys worry
but in this circumstance there is no
need
okay hmm
chingada though Jamie's gonna have a
look for it we also give it a go he's
been away for a while and I think
Singhania is probably sitting on a dead
in yellow somewhere as well and then
also just on that whole night about the
dead in the other I noticed cemented all
but even the hyenas aren't eating them
then that's why the sauna might be
second it is not the Highness didn't go
there is because that I found four
separate hyena drag marks of dead in the
other today alone on Bushwick and I only
covered the area around the Morty River
and that means there's probably a whole
bunch more up on this these little river
systems the Gary Cutler and the one of
puffles a dam the one of quarry pan so
the hyenas are just full that's why they
didn't eat all of that in yella that
where husana was ok have a look
oh hello Coral
Oh jumping coral I'm gonna pop his head
around the corner
Oh is he dashed up and up and away is
dashed up up and away
now I've actually found in Ghana in this
tree before on a hot day
in the summer months just lazing on the
branch of this giant jackal be an ass is
not there today let's carry on
hello dee use a new viewer welcome Dee
would like to know where in Africa are
we well we are in the southernmost
country in Africa South Africa we are in
the eastern most province of the said
country while the northeastern province
which is called the Impala langa which
means Puma means to come out Ranga means
Sun so east where the Sun rises we are
then inside the greater Kruger National
Park which is 2.7 million hectares of an
offense wilderness wonderland and then
we go smaller where within the sixty
thousand hectares of the sabi sands
private game reserve which is open to
Kruger there's no fences and here we go
them smaller we are currently on Juma
private game reserve in the northwestern
corner of the said sabi sand again
reserve that is exactly where we are an
Africa and if one to go even even more
miniscule I am on a road called Gauri
cut line which runs north from Central
Road and I am looking for leopards and
Davis giggling behind me doesn't take
much to amused ester
I'm not sure what Jamie's found I think
did you hear that but anyway let's go
find the heart which is a really nice
surprise and when I say I found hyenas I
actually had absolutely nothing to do
with it this one is entirely on
eagle-eyed Senzo who has really got his
spotting eyes on this morning afternoon
what is wrong with me it's this
afternoon oh we got here at the back I
think it might just be no no it is not
it is pretty by the looks of things so
what are we doing here my girls know we
often get asked where hyenas go during
the day and the answer is two places
just like this a nice big shady area
especially around drainage lines which
are dried up riverbeds they'll go and
they'll spend the day here and then at
night return to the den site that looks
like sucker there it is sucker and
pretty spending their afternoon curled
up in the shade how very interesting
well that's good news for us if
perchance the Hinds decide not to go to
the den site before the end of the TV
show tonight least we've got some hyenas
well done Senzo you would not believe
the spot he pulled off there is another
possible reason for they're meant to be
curled up here underneath a quarry bush
and that is that they could potentially
be a leopard with a kill somewhere here
now for two hyenas against in Ghana they
probably would have taken his kill from
him if it were on the ground so either
they're not here because of the kill or
if they are here because of a kill
that's in a tree and I've been checking
out the big trees around the area I
probably won't stay with these two for
that long because they're gonna be flat
flat for now but we can always come back
here a little bit later but there's
nothing in this tree sadly most done for
but it does remind me because of where
we are at the time that / little husana
had such a bad limp and it was when
young Gillian knocked him off the tree
he was trying to climb and he was having
such a bad day and then he got caught
unawares by a hyena and had to go
running up the closest tree which
happened to be a thorn tree and when he
tried to get down off to the hyena was
gone it was just pulling out Tufts of
his fur left right and center was when
he was about a year old also I found him
sleeping in a rhino midden then
obviously like this patch this was where
I suspected Corky was hiding akashi's
cooling herself down that's so cool
spraying dirt over her belly Rosalind
you want to know if hyenas are smart
smarter than chimps hmm it's difficult
to really have my fine thanks sorry I
just choked over my own saliva it's
difficult to really compare intelligence
they're certainly smarter than someone
who chokes on her own spit but to
compare them to chimps would be it's a
difficult one they have done cognition
studies and they are very very close to
chimps in terms of the way that we
define intelligence where they're
actually beat chimps is in a study that
was done with a puzzle so - two
chimpanzees were given a test there was
a piece of meat on a Ledge that they
couldn't reach and to get it or to get
it out of a box or whatever the test
happened to be it doesn't really matter
they had to pull two ropes in opposite
directions so the chimps figured it
asked marginally faster than the hyenas
and the hyenas got it pretty quickly and
grabbed the meat then what they did was
they took one individual that knew the
puzzle out and put an individual in who
didn't know the puzzle who'd never seen
the puzzle before and within split
seconds the hyenas had communicated to
each other what needed to be done and
the box or the puzzle was opened and
they had the food they actually did that
faster than chimpanzees so in terms of
their social relationship with each
other they are actually slightly more
intelligent
the way that in that sort of puzzle
scenario so they've been given all sorts
of puzzles to figure out boxes that only
unlock a certain way I watched a
documentary on a very low ranked male
who was given a puzzle and he knew how
to figure it out and he worked it out
and he was given plenty of time to do so
and then he was taken away and then he
was put back into that situation but
with the rest of the clan and he
completely feigned ignorance while they
all sort of looked around at this box
and and then eventually lost interest
and ignored it he pretended he didn't
know what was going on and then as soon
as the high-ranked individuals lost
interest and moved away then he went and
unlocked the box and got his piece of
meat no he's not stupid he knows if he
done locked it before that he never
would have got the prize like kindness
or smart creatures there's a vast amount
going on behind those eyes one of the
reasons why I enjoy them as much as I do
that and they're hilarious you think
it's a mating pair if it's a mating pair
then we would have big trouble then we
would have big trouble because it would
mean that pretties Cubs were not
terribly well so no I think we're okay
there but I think they're friends and
actually sins is not far off he said do
you know this could be a mating pair and
I said no but actually is not far off
because males will befriend females with
Cubs and be very nice to the Cubs be
very gentle in the hope that the female
actually befriends him and remembers
that when it comes time to mate now
Caroline's wondering about whether or
not hyenas will mate like lions and
leopards and whether it goes on for days
the Easter cycle does last for a few
days but it's not nearly as a frequent
as the matings of lions and leopards
it's also a very different situation so
as you know the male lion or the male
leopard has a barbed penis and it causes
a lot of pain to the female she gets
very aggressive it and happens every
couple of minutes even though it's
Shh you're talking it scandalized
scandalized at the talk of all of this
making of new baby animals right are you
done now
can I finish speaking yes no thank you
so the meeting doesn't go on for day or
at least it doesn't go on as regularly
for days as it does with the Lions of
the leopards and it's a glassed for a
lot longer so the mating sessions of a
matter of leopards or lions go on for 30
seconds give or take I mean it never
really extends much beyond that for
which I imagine the female is
exceedingly thankful because I don't
think there's any kind of I think it's a
30 unenjoyable experience for her but
for hyenas it actually goes on for quite
a long time and they end up similar to
mating dogs with a sort of a tie
together so even when they finished the
actual population process the male then
dismounts and they remain joined
together for a period of time so no not
quite like lions and leopards of also of
course the male also has to do some
romancing it's not like a female leopard
that goes and throws herself bottom
first at the male in the case of hyenas
the male really has to he has to put in
some serious time and effort he's got to
dance around the female he does a lot of
bowing a lot of playing a lot of running
around and making a fool of himself
acting a clown and the female eventually
decides whether or not she can actually
be bothered with him and that's why
friendships work they work so so well in
hyena society it's something similar to
baboons male baboons will have partners
that they make friends with well as
thoroughly entertaining as our two
hyenas are being right here and right
now it's a go see what James's are up to
in the Masai Mara where apparently one
has found something to snack on
well this Heian is also been very
entertaining this is Anna Anatolian as
we've recently discovered she's just
left the den and she's eating a lobster
oh no it's not a lobster it looks like a
stick no it's definitely not a stick I
think it is the it's a piece of
wildebeest but I cannot tell which piece
it is don't know does look like a mane
but it doesn't look like the neck so
difficult to say which one which bit but
I'm serving also the approach of the
Michigan State University hyena
researchers so any luck we'll have a bit
more information for you at some stage
so she's what all run about a quarter of
a mile from the den she was obviously
feeling that peckish needed some Sunday
tea and she's found herself a long
rotten piece of wildebeest to eat I
would like to be having scones and
strawberry jam and tea right now but I'm
not I am going to watch the hyena have a
rotting piece of wildebeest for its tea
then I suspect you will return to the
den
must be a bit of nick surely that
definitely does look like a bit of a bit
of mein now I don't know where any of
the others are but what I will tell you
is that this is very interesting because
as I have banged on for ages I've said
to you that there is a huge amount of
dead stuff out here that just rots into
the ground that nothing that doesn't get
eaten
it is scavenged from time to time and
that is quite possibly what you're
seeing here there's a all amongst this
grassland there are bits of dead flesh
that is either gonna rot into the ground
or be picked up by scavengers most of it
will rot and that is one of the key
things that our ancient hominid
ancestors found it's one of the key
things that brought them onto these
Plains in the first place
was this underutilized sort of resource
of food that they could go and scavenge
so far from being hunters I say we but I
mean of course wasn't living the same
species back then our ancestors were
scavengers and they were scavenging much
like this hyena but probably using tools
rather than teeth and safari hearty you
asked a question that has entirely
slipped my mind and I'm going to ask for
it again
whoever again is that possible oh we
ever seen a hyena eating grass I was
actually thinking about that yesterday
after watching husana spent most of his
day behaving like a wildebeest I don't
think I have seen a hyena eating grass I
suspect in this area you you know you'd
have to be with them quite a lot to see
it because it would happen so quickly
you know they live in green grass and so
they'd probably just have a few chomps
almost without your noticing it but the
do man it could be much like watching
the leopards you know that come across a
nice long tough
with leaves that were sort of green and
of their choosing that kind of things
that dogs and cats when they grass chews
and I can't I can't cool ever seeing a
hyena making such a selection and then
having a bite to eat of that grass so
I'm gonna say no Safari hot I don't
think they do eat as much as the
leopards or the Lions do I wonder if it
isn't because there have fewer parasites
possibly because their digestive systems
of that much more acidic that much more
powerful but I'm really not sure
interesting that husana is spinning
quite so much time eating grass he's
obviously not feeling very comfy in the
belly no very few animals can get ill
from eating rotten meat out here Paula
and it's you know they've all evolved to
utilize this resource and so no I don't
think so look I don't know what would
happen if a wild dog ate rotten meat -
they don't eat rotten meat normally in
fact I've never seen one eating rotten
meat I've only ever seen them eating
fresh kills
likewise cheetah I'm not just told the
cheetah wouldn't scavenge if it could
but 99% of the time I've ever seen in
fact a hunt percent of the time I've
seen them eating they've been eating
fresh meat I'm sure there are records of
them scavenging and I'm sure there are
records of what our dog scavenging but
I've never seen it and I wonder if
because their strategy of feeding is
that they eat fresh meat they may not be
adapted to eating rotten stuff like this
and I think that if you look at our
examples of ourselves as human beings
you know we have a fairly limited or the
food that we eat has to be in a certain
condition before we can consume it what
will make us ill and that's because you
know with our lives as they are we've
adapted to eating cooked food most of
the time we've adapted to eating food
that is not rotten
because of weed rotting meat we can get
very ill to a certain extent having this
what a lazy aged steak is about forty
days is that old can't be 40 days old
sure let's give it some flavor for sure
no this is the only high you know that I
can see for miles and I can see for
miles
Shandra are you are asking a question
for your six-year-old and your
six-year-old is obviously interested if
Highness can be Pitts Chandra how do we
answer that so basically can they be
domesticated can they be if you raise
them from little will they tame and the
answer is to a certain extent there are
parts of the world in Ethiopia and
Nigeria two examples where hyenas have
become completely habituated human
beings on foot I'm not sure that they
would ever tame like a dog if you tried
to tame them over generations like we
did with wolves at one stage and maybe
they might but not an adult like this no
and a love like this would remain very
afraid of human beings and if cornered
very dangerous to human beings a hyena
is a ferocious predator they are they
are phenomenal creatures and they don't
have quite the fashion sense of the
Lions or leopards or cheetahs or wild
dogs and they really are like thee I
suppose they're a little bit like a
mafia organization that runs a city and
kind of beneath the radar they shape
this environment hugely with their
activities I think that we have spotted
a water Pig well spotted Bungay water
Pig and a baby water Pig
and the hyena of course has not seen the
Waterpik now I've always been amazed at
how animals live in this grass and I'm
not sure if I said this on air or off
air yesterday but I think the length of
the grass in this area profoundly alters
the behavior of the animals here and I
think if you were to take these animals
and stick them in a place out juma they
would almost be confused about what to
do because of the difference in the
grass none of them even the Lions in the
high season can see over the top of the
grass now you can imagine how impossibly
frightening that must be for a water Pig
while you think of walking through the
grass unable to see unable to know if
you're going to stumble upon a lion or
not go across the Sydney who's got a
leopard a tortoise instead of finding
goes on I found another leopard look at
that this is a leopard tota so you can
see that the leopard tortoise is very
what is trying to go underneath the
branch I just saw the movement of the
branch coming up so this turtle must be
feeling some heat at the moment and the
grass I can see they are not that very
green but probably you might have been
grazing somewhere here because the green
is starting to come out you can see
there way is coming from he was eating
the grass is somewhere there so now he's
just looking for some shade to hide a
little bit so this is the leopard
tortoise and leopard tortoise so very
much proactive like any other Tata
during the dry season before the dry
season they go and collect quite a lot
of water in order to supply themselves
when is too dry and you will see if you
pick the turtle up during the dry season
he's just going to urinate very slimming
water that water is there in order to
save him during that season you are not
allowed to pick them up if you pick them
up you will be jeopardizing their life
just leave them if it's too slow to
close the
a tickler time wait for him to pass
don't try and help him because you will
then be causing him a lot of harm he
won't feel anything but if he's to drive
for a long period they won't have water
to survive so you can see now that he is
hiding under the under the dry branch
and it's very much camouflaged it's not
very easy for the UH predators to see
the money's hiding like that northern
land the rains the supposed to begin
already by now because we are talking we
are heading towards the mid-october and
me to October normally is when the
animals are starting to give birth but
now it means the rain is late to come
which might cause quite a lot of
mortalities on animals as well as their
young because now I can promise you is
very hot but I'm very excited because
the areas that have been now it rained a
little bit last week but grasses are
starting to get excited and is some
green grass coming out the problem is
one when the green grass is starting to
come back after being stimulated by the
rains or the fires you will see animals
concentrating by the small patch and
that gives grass is quite a lot of
pressure to recover Becky I haven't seen
the huge total at the moment but by the
tenth the day I was doing some
presentation from the tent I saw that
there is an old tortoise shell from a
hinge totter showing that the is a hinge
totter in the area for now I am only
knowing the leopard total as well as
they each torta
so the hitch daughter is that one the
body is flat and it's not big as the
leopard tota which is more round and
grow big turtle
one of those animals which can be able
to survive for quite a long period them
and the crocodiles can survive 150 years
and more so once they've got the shell
they can survive much longer
although they do have some of the
Predators such as the ground hunters but
for now let's cross over to my other
colleague who is also having something
very interesting for you by the Kenya in
Masai Mara
at the moment yes we have got a bird we
haven't moved a hyena still eating its
disgusting meal and so we've looking at
a female black-bellied busted as far as
I can work out I think that's what it is
the females are little bit difficult to
distinguish excuse me I had a small
young there the reason I told you it was
the Dino kirsten was going to mention it
tonight yeah and now she can't haha
right so black-bellied busted I'm just
quickly interject or did you get the
white Billy Buster's here as well black
varied mustard yes that is a female
black Billy's mustard
just looking at the females will look
very similar no let's go with
black-bellied I have seen a male around
here Sharon I don't think the females
make the call
I think only the male's make that
champagne cork popping call
who's gonna be quiet for 20 seconds it's
quite a nice tone of sound of crickets
all around us
now for me and this weeping no grunting
ultimate cliche of the cry of the
fishies or the sound of Africa but for
me it's that it's lying in my bed at
night in the bush and listening to the
crickets and the smell of dew on the
grass
it makes me think y'all I'm in the wild
now
we will pop back to the Dane at some
stage that how you know researchers have
just told me that there are two other
Cubs there now so we will pop back but
they're not that many we did we did we
have the double or we did a double and
mistake them okay there we go now you
don't have to look all the way into my
brain through my eyes good okay let's
have one last look here at our high in a
friend and then maybe we'll go you know
what I don't think we are gonna get back
I think I'm going to wait here with her
and I believe that sitters has now
dispensed with The Tortoise part of his
sighting so the turtle was just bringing
us a lot of luck as now I managed to get
hold of the little chief wasana I can
see that he is somewhere high up day I'm
just gonna drive up a little bit so that
you can have a better sight at the
moment so Hasan is just right here with
me after a very long search he was going
in the middle of the drainage because
it's too hot at the moment here where we
are so I can see that he is right here
and he is now on his way probably to the
Calico pen as he is not very far
considering the distance you can see
it's just a less than 500 meters to the
Calico pen so I'm just going to make a
turn here so that we can have a good
sighting
and Gaea a to check lever is not easy
because this animals they can be able to
conceal very easily and use the thick
bushes so here now he has been walking
by the inaccessible areas it was never
easy to do shaking now we saw that sex
at the beginning heading towards this
direction but we just lost where he was
going
then we judged that he's heading to the
waterhole we were just checking
everywhere now
this area where we are we are trying
this area for the second time because we
were worried that the tracks got
disappeared in the same area so we do
check where he has gone past but it's
not easy because these are the animals
who normally walk and hunt at the same
time tracks just got disappeared in any
way so he will be coming out here in few
minutes so it's just that at the moment
he's taking his time
so you can see there he is not what is
trying to listen because the birds are
making some noise and they are not
picking up making noise because of his
presence that one
I can guarantee you none of this bird
spotted him yet
maybe the some other animals because
most of the birds I'm hearing are ground
grellus who are nesting on the ground
maybe other prey animals are walking
towards the nest and they are being
focused because of that
so I can see that this cat is just going
underneath the shade at the moment so he
might have some water and rest somewhere
by the Gallagher pen and thank you very
very much for all the comments about
finding the little chief so he's trying
to sniff and investigate things there
and now he is going to defecate they so
a few few months ago
I was lucky to see the Ines eating the
droppings of Tigana when it was still
very warm a few seconds after he
defecated the hyannis started eating and
finished everything even it so that is
just big sign that in the bush nothing
is wasted everything is recycled where
the droppings wood grass is everything
is just recyclate so you can see that
the stomach is not looking big anymore
so he lost weight a little bit from the
stomach compared to last night now if
anything come forward I can promise you
is going to be able to dive pounce and
catch something so before we get
disappeared I am going to keep following
and see if we can improve this sighting
so now while I'm following the little
chief let's cross over to Jamie and see
what is following at the moment you can
see that this dong has subsided so well
done to Sydney for finding the little
chief that is a very good start I'm
going towards buffle sagar dam in the
hope that this nice warm weather 30 what
was it again 30-something degrees 80
something degrees somewhere on there 31
thank you which was right 87 989 87 87
degrees Fahrenheit that was marvelous
well done we got there eventually I have
not found any sign of a kill round those
hyenas so I don't I think they were just
there sleeping they couldn't sleep
somewhere during the day so we're just
gonna do a quick search of bubbles look
damn I don't know where ting gone is
gone I mean he really was just a he was
just a shot in the dark so to speak
fortunately not in the dark because it's
a lot more difficult to find things in
the dark we're gonna do one check of
bubbles look damn hopefully the
elephants are coming to have a drink
there it's nice and hot they might even
want a bit of a swim
and then we'll make our way back towards
the hyena den for the drawing in of the
evening and we'll just have to keep our
fingers crossed I hope everyone out
there is doing all their good luck
superstitions Collins you would like to
know why the wheel is on the right side
of the car because we are on in the
southern hemisphere
everything gets switched upside down so
it's we're basically a mirror image of
the Northern Hemisphere you know we do
something's mirrored the rights and the
live for the lips on the right
no we drive on the left in South Africa
that is why the steering wheel is on the
right so we drive on the left-hand side
of the road whereas most other countries
drive on the right-hand side of the road
now we're on the left as is of course
the UK fortunately because otherwise I
would have had a terrible time driving
there I would have got very confused
about which way and who had the right of
way and and passing on the left
that's an surrenders not that we don't
do that in South Africa anyway we
shouldn't it doesn't mean we don't yes
that's the reason that the steering
wheel is on the right and of course they
don't have to relearn everything the
gear stick would be over here and I
would be all confused and just be a
disaster one thing I've noticed with
people who come out here note or learn
to drive these vehicles is they tend to
drive with their left wheel just off the
road and they get exponentially more
flat tires than we do there's an Impala
for everybody fortunately perfectly
centered neither left nor right-handed
decided something
I'm just thinking about my conversation
about flipped hemispheres and thinking
about Kenya that's why the stereo would
have to be in the middle of the car
otherwise it'd be terribly confusing
being that close to the equator we're
now starting to look very carefully for
any signs of females who are straining
that is not of course a female that is a
male Impala the difference being for our
new viewers it has horns so that's not
an automatic giveaway with male and
female antelope there are some species
where the females do have horns
Thomson's gazelle for example in the
Mara
although the female's horns are truly
pathetic but they do have horns but the
impala only the males have horns well as
intriguing as that conversation was
let's go across the little chief as
Sidney predicted he's quenching his
thirst we have got wasana who has just
arrived now by the Galago pan and I'm
sure he's going to have a very long
drink considering effect that Hassan has
not been to any of the waterhole
yesterday and the day before I've been
following her sign off a couple of days
now the last time he had some water it
was by this small pot report what
potholes where the water was just stuck
there after the rains so now at least is
having some fresh water so you can hear
that the territorial squirrel is now
starting to be vocal because him and
these spotted cares don't get along
so that one I can promise you is about
the leopard yes I understand this kind
of animals they do make calls against
the other small predators but they do
make quite a lot of warning calls when
it comes to these letters you will hear
the other birds joining and other bugs
as well joining the chorus so the
mobbing behavior is normal in this area
he is quite very much tasty indeed as I
indicated I was very much surprised as
well seeing that he is not visiting any
of the waterhole since he got those two
dead Nala's by the drainage line so he
didn't want to move there maybe why he
did not move there is because he did not
manage to take any of those carcasses up
into the nearest tree which made him to
be protective and stay on the ground
so normally these cats comes here by the
Gallagher pen during the sunset so you
can see that indeed he has been very
much testy and as he was eating the
grass this morning maybe that also made
him very well
it made him to be very thirsty
so it is good sometimes to be a leopard
because coming to the waterhole
the competition is minimal you don't
have to worry about any other species so
he just by yourself
so he's enjoying his status of becoming
the little chief here in Zuma James and
this is not a natural water indeed is a
man-made dam so every time the water is
pumped and at the moment I can see that
the water is coming in from the side you
can see there so this is quite very much
fresh water for these animals
so something people must have to realize
is that when managing a natural system
and put a fence around an area we got to
take a full accountability when is dry
season because it's not fair for the
animals to stay in and when this drought
we don't provide water because under
normal circumstance animals when it's a
shortage of water showed us your food
they will be doing what is called a
migration what we have been seeing by
the Maasai Mara happening because that
is much more natural and they are not
like fenced in so whereby they cannot
make it in in terms of migration think
is fair enough to provide them with
water
so now let's go to the Maasai Mara
where James is having some hyenas at the
moment so husana and the highness
they here we are still with Ana Thalia
and Natalia she is about to walk behind
the car I'm just gonna move quickly I'll
show you where she is in relation to the
din
basically the den is behind that large
flat topped by the nighties tree there
and I think she's probably going to go
back there
bring her Cubs dart and they'll play for
us all night long that's definitely
what's going to happen she had a bit of
mud to drink from literally a hole of
mud she then made a burp that went as
follows the and now she seems to be
going back towards her din Cathy I think
that they you might find that their ears
are less tattered here because they
don't live in thorny bush I think the
ears probably get Abbot at it from the
thorny bush they're in them in South
Africa I wonder also if they don't have
more scraps with lions there because
they steal a lot more I think in South
Africa than they do here I wonder if
that isn't one of the reasons but you do
see some very chatty eared hyenas here
that's it this one is particularly
pretty ears all right this far follow a
Natalya back to her home
one or two taupe I around the place now
I still can't see the horseshoe on her
bottom can anyone else
Justin you saying you can see it let me
get a bit closer and we'll see if we can
find a horseshoe on her bottom
both shoe on the right side of her
bottom well zoom quickie Bunga let's see
if there's a horseshoe on the right side
of her bottom there there is there's a
horseshoe on the right bottom you see
I'd never have noticed that unless
somebody had said there's a horseshoe on
the right side of her bottom there is
most certainly looks like a horseshoe
brand fascinating I suppose there are
ways and means of identifying these
creatures some people are now able to
just look at them in the eyes and say
well that's obviously whoever it is I
absolutely hopeless at that
for this glorious scene and that
gorgeous
oh there we go sorry
Kirsten managed to read your question
wrong Gabby she said with a hyena died
of a hyena a [ __ ] hyenas ate and that's
why I was completely silent but a panda
you asked me what a human died if at
eight would a hyena ate I think that if
a human being tried to eat that rotting
wildebeest she had a go at I think you
probably could die yes you probably
could give yourself sufficient blood
poisoning to die but I am NOT a medical
scientist so I couldn't say for sure
let's go a little bit forward I don't
think a hyena would die for how you know
it what a hyena aids
she's moving now the scones and tea time
is over
away from the not sure we won't say
traumas from the trials of motherhood if
you like
[Applause]
chosen a relatively nice smooth place to
walk through which is great for us
interested in why suddenly she moved off
and where on earth the rest of them are
all right we're gonna keep following her
I'm not going to lose her will I'm not
good I'm going to try not to lose it
let's go back to cities and hasanah so
you can see that now husana has just
gone to his little cave this is his
normal little cave he has been here on
several occasion I've seen him and is
quite very difficult to see him from the
road about today I think the stomach is
too big I don't know if he's gonna be
able to fit in there because normally he
goes there sleep and lean against the
wall so the Franklin's were just giving
him some tough time during my arrival
here so you can see that now he's
showing some signs of sleeping he might
be sleeping anytime soon
so you can see the breathing rate that
after consuming quite a lot of water the
stomach in there doesn't have too much
space but if any animal come forward you
will see he's going to forget that he
has just been to the waterhole and the
stomach is full he will attempt to take
it down that is normal
so the Sun is very much hot at the
moment this guy is open and it's very
much difficult for these animals to
attack us why because of the following
reasons when this kind of predators sees
me in this car they see me and the car
as one object but if I move my hands
rapidly like this is when he is going to
start looking at me and start
investigating so these animals normally
if I don't get off the car and if I
don't sit by the dashboard or sit by the
seat on top is when he is going to be
very much calm and he won't do anything
but if I can now jump off the car I will
see he's just going to get off and run
away because these animals they still
have got a human natural fear if they
are cornered that can be dangerous if
you look there by that little cave way
is if I can just walk him and surprise
him I think it might be difficult for
him to jump up instead of going up you
might come towards me so this kind of
animals they don't want to be cornered
you can see those dangerous canines
which can grow and get up to eight
millimeters so those are the very strong
weapons for these animals to catch their
prey one bite on the neck that can take
a prey down but if it's a small prey
they will just if say small prey like a
bad one pow they're just going to kill
it the clouds by these legs they are so
powerful you can see the mouth is open
at all times because he's trying to
inhale quite a lot of air now is the
time you can see now that he is fitting
by his a little cave so now let's say
cross over to Jamie who is on the move
trying to find something very
interesting for you this afternoon
anything I'm trying to find anything for
you this afternoon
I'm hoping to find in Ghana for Brent
but I really haven't had any luck at all
see this bird stays still no it's not
going to stay still maybe it is hold on
might have to settle for a bird that's a
Kingfisher but it's gone have you got
one
oh not flu senses really got it you got
it
since my go too far back okay
hold on everyone there it is there it is
I can see it now
doo doo doo doo doo doo oh whoa too far
back a bit okay there looks like Brown
crowned brown headed Kingfisher not
brown crowned too many crowns and heads
and wood what are they called Kingfisher
goodness
I've got word would mix up today I can't
I can't just ignore everything I say
because clearly I have no idea what I'm
talking about
I've been watching Boston Legal recently
it's it's called word salad
I've got word salad I can't seem to say
the words that I'm intending to say that
is a Kingfisher we are eagerly awaiting
the return of the woodland Kingfisher
there here we go
imagine if we all present it like that
what a disaster that would be
okay what is a nice little surprise
hoping it might be a striped but it
doesn't look like it we also look okay
well that was enthralling while spotted
sensor he did an amazing job of showing
you that bird considering I couldn't
even see it
it's go across to Brent who has also
found a bird for you we have a beautiful
tawny eagle in golden light this is the
birds are going my wedge there because
nothing else's Oh off it goes absolutely
gorgeous
now the reason I'm quite interested yet
maybe the tawny eagle is going to change
my luck is because they were actually
two twenties and a battle ear so there
might be something here it could however
be one of these in yellow could you
might have expired from the dry
interesting to see that and where's it
gone eyes taken off the second Tony was
on that he's gone now this might be with
I'm just trying to listen to see if I
can hear anything there's any squirrels
alarm calling around they might of
course just been some confusion Paul I
would like to know do we get Falcons on
GMAT we do not very often what Falcons
have I seen on Jima I've seen a
peregrine falcon and I've seen a
Eurasian hobby Falcon and of course we
do get the Eastern red-footed which is
now called an Amur for Caen and no and
the western red footed Falcon nozzle
those will generally come once the rains
have arrived because there are many
insectivores those two last Falcon
species there's a possibility we might
have some other transient Falcons that
appear every now and then but not
resident
you know better dear
juvenile battery of course and takes
them about eight years to reach their
adult plumage well I'm gonna just sit
there for a little bit and hopefully a
leopard pops its head up that's why all
these Raptors are here but in the
meantime we're gonna send you all the
way back to the Masai Mara where unlike
South Africa where we're sitting in
bright Sun the Sun is setting beautiful
I are still with our hyena but Pongo
just created a magnificent picture from
the rapidly changing sunset it is very
very pretty indeed magical magical stuff
everybody magical now don't come to me
pongo I'm taking an illegal photograph
one more legal photograph then you can
come to me okay go oh no the sun's
coming out to care where the hyena is
moving up ahead in front of us very nice
going sort of towards the den but not
entirely I wonder if we're not going to
build it mm-hmm you're worried you've
zoomed in yes I see that okay let's see
if we can silhouette that elephant
against the sunset and would be quite
pretty very pretty Ubbe pretty
gosh it's the first bit of nice life
we've had all afternoon it's been very
cloudy until now
you just see if we can't get this
elephant
with the Sun behind it
as our hyena hero of the day heads back
towards her den and an elephant in fact
we might get her and the elephant as
well
fast
gene yep no adult hyenas don't go into
dance normally we have seen this Heiner
in fact go into a den though and so even
if she was unsafe she'd normally just
leave you know they're fast enough to
just run away sorry the reason I didn't
get the elephants silhouetted was that
he's trying to make his way back to his
head I didn't want to get him between
him and the herd oh look at that for
picture isn't it gorgeous stunning
nature just sent out a spotlight
fantastic going to take another legal
photograph don't care what anyone says
too pretty
camera is doing what it's supposed to be
doing
magic
now my cameras definitely doing
something very odd oh I've changed the
setting that's why I put it on to
automatic
I'm sure you're all fascinated by that
ah it's his invalid lens that's
definitely not true
a hyena sort of circling back to the den
we will intercept her shortly yes April
it's completely illegal to take
photographs you'll probably find very
shortly a helicopter will arrive and
take me away now what it is is we made
it
semi illegal to take photographs while
we were live because that was in the
days when we only had cameras that go
pink and they make that horrible kind of
lens snapping shutter shutter sound and
that's why we made it illegal to take
photographs while live but the odd one
you can take and my one doesn't have a
noisy shutter you can put it on the
silent shutter and so well off the time
you don't even know the time doing it
[Applause]
I'm afraid I missed that piston what was
that
[Applause]
yes yes we started off doing the sneeze
or the cough see you would get ha ha and
said you here Brent here Smith coughing
it's not because he's got consumption
our hyena was circling around this way I
don't see her anymore
you got it when guys got her yeah she's
going straight back towards the den I'm
gonna go in this way because I don't
want to get between the Sun and the BBC
full crew
I think they'll take a dim view of that
hey ry which or take a picture for our
next documentary I'm sure they don't
speak like that but they're not I said I
said remove well between us in the Sun
the child gets in retinas hi now we've
been out all day oh there's a hole hold
on everyone
[Applause]
sorry about that
I'm really hoping they don't have been
for it and that they have to go away
soon and are going to bump into the
Michigan State University hyena
researchers I've never met them before
I'm certainly going to have to say hello
to them so maybe we should link the way
I'm just saying don't have to meet them
too good idea let's go to their best
friend in the world
Jamie Patterson I miss them we had so
much fun with a hyena researchers
especially when they raided our our
storeroom full of food I have please
tell James cellar I have absolutely
nothing to report I have more Impala if
you really you know keen on seeing an
Impala there we go look at that
marvelous that is James says apparently
the researchers said that they missed me
so much I miss them too even if they did
offer to give James Henry lessons on how
in a behavior what's the second one's
name I'm so thrilled that one's a lovo
one of waffles as Cubs is apparently
called a Lobo was the other one cursed
Rimmer Rimmer it's awesome about that
I'll ask them about that
harima so at least one became a Lobo
there you go since our South African
impact us our African stamp on the
Maasai Mara one of waffles as Cubs is
named after a Lobo syrup marvellous well
this is quite pretty the glass looks
gold the Impala look healthy because you
can't see the details on them and very
very very pregnant
I can't wait till am start coming out
last time I did a close-up view of an
Impala around about this time of year
you could actually see the baby start to
kick obviously they don't kick all the
time but you could see movement in her
stomach I think the lights right for
that though I always feel as though the
females are now walking around their
tails so tucked under their bottoms and
it looks as though they're trying to
hold the babies in that's just how
impala have their tails but when they're
that pregnant that's what it looks like
they try to keep anything from from
popping out too soon shame all that
weight on those spindly legs especially
after this dry season now what is it
with me and animals at the moment okay
he's at least cleaning the inside of his
thigh Impala meticulous groomers of
course they keep themselves very clean
that's why they always look so shiny and
beautiful they constantly comb through
their fur not with a comb comb with a
teeth but they do comb their fur bony
bony even this beautiful golden light
can't hide the hip bones sticking out
Shambala it's coming
don't you worry it's going green Paul
our twins are a possibility with Impala
but incredibly rare
so it's possible but very unlikely so I
just said the same thing twice in
different ways basically by using
different words that's what's known as
killing time so there's not very much
space inside a female Impala
also remember that once those Impala
lambs are born they have to be able to
keep up with the rest of the herd with
the mothers otherwise they become
instant cat food wine a food or jackal
food or bird food so they're born with
extraordinarily long leg
and that means that it's all sort of
folded up inside mum there's not very
much room so in parlor lambs generally
aren't born it's not too bored at one
time it's not very good for the mother
so that gene the twin gene isn't really
selected for in the wild because a lot
of the time those twins don't survive
they're just born a little bit too small
an especially in dry season like this
chances are that a mother supporting two
fetuses as opposed to one is going to
really really struggle so no twins are
not common just possible were born in a
jumble of legs and can wait can wait
watch them take those wobbly first steps
that's my goal for the mmm actually I'm
going on leave on Wednesday I was gonna
say by the end of this work cycle I want
to get a live-in parlor birth I think
that might be a bit optimistic let's go
with by the end of the year how about
that we'll go with that onwards she
cried let's go see what's happening at
the hyena den
mm-hmm Frances it actually happens quite
a lot Francis wants to know if it's
possible that's pregnant animals have
passed away during birth
it is possible it does happen the
probably the most common animal that it
happens to is hyenas
most of the time they're first-time
mothers will either lose their first
litter or at least the first cub just
due to the extremely strenuous birthing
process involved with their unique
genital structure the only other animal
that has as much of a difficult time as
hyenas is humans because of the way that
our pelvis is shaped in order to allow
us to walk upright actually spoken about
this quite a lot recently it's amazing
how topics go through stages but it is a
very difficult process for hyenas most
other animals are slightly easier the
way that they're structured on four legs
means that it goes quite quickly quite
easily but the animals do die a lot of
them Nala that we've seen haven't
necessarily died giving birth but
they've died in the late stages of
pregnancy because there's just that much
more pressure on their bodies trying to
support themselves and their fetuses and
it's just it's really very strenuous the
same goes for still though stillborns
there'll be a few still bones so
absolutely it can happen less common in
the wild than it is in say certain
species of cow or breeds of cow or
horses things that have been bred by
humans to change the their physical
structure in a way that actually does in
the end make a creative fetus that's a
lot bigger than mom should be able to
handle is able to handle in the wild the
birthing process comes quite naturally
because well these these genetics are
the ones that have been selected for for
so long
I mean little boys I need to go to the
den and see what's happening I can't
stand the suspense anymore I need to
know four in four
him for a week like last week where we
said hello and that was that at least
sins are managed to manage to spot two
hyenas that we can go to to kill time
they're not at the den robber sins saved
the day
twins in all animals are quite rare in
in terms of weight let me rephrase that
now and I've dug myself into a hole I'm
trying to say the twins are rare but
that's actually nonsense because let
because leopards will have twins or
they're not twins twins but they'll have
two babies or three babies lions or two
babies three babies in animals that are
designed to have one baby two babies are
unusual that's sort of what I was trying
to say
so like elephants and elephants a twin
elephant birth is possible but
exceptionally rare it's such a large
baby same goes for giraffe now at one
stage giraffe were twins we're thought
to be a great deal more common than they
actually are because people were not
realizing because mother's the mothers
are so tall they actually move very far
away from their youngsters
so they'd see one mother and two calves
and immediately assume that those were
twins so for a long time giraffe twins
were thought to be more common than they
really are another animal where it's got
to be born with the longest legs
imaginable so that the poor thing can
actually keep up with mum mom's legs are
two metres long she takes big steps
zebra again another example born with
phenomenally long disproportionately
long legs
I remember watching James's zebra birth
when he filmed the zebra birth just here
with Dave I think it was an amazing
scene and marveling at the sheer size of
that foal
it's Dave on camera and James just down
the road here
so animals that have one baby generally
only have one baby it was really
profound so what I'm trying to say don't
have ever heard of hippo twins again
similar to elephants it's probably
possible but unlikely
all right I'm gonna go see if I can
charm the hyenas out of the den let's go
see if Bryn's charm has won him any
animals
sweet blue all is the answer and I've
heard some alarming squirrels and Pilar
is looking in that direction and this is
of course outside of our travelers but
it's worth a look of course the
squirrels in our silent wind is quite
strong their wonder if the squirrels
were just having a little argument who
knows it's quite deep inside hoffmans
then pilot go and pilot looks very
relaxed set carry on I'm basically doing
a boundary patrol staring at the sand
wishing for a leopard track to cross in
I do not hold out much confidence to be
honest I've got an update from welcome
warriors which really last was where
Johnny is the only missing cat is Tigana
lost tracks were south but no one's seen
him for a while for a couple of days
either in the north or the south so who
knows maybe older tingitana will show up
well how come we're he's far from yeah
either option if we get no lucky as to
maybe check the eastern sides of chipped
waffle kochava and I think with Tandy
and subbu you having boxes they're our
odds are not good
I think she's moved further to the east
into sort of Iran cheated planes Camp
Jim Adam on cheetah planes that area
which we used to see her in occasionally
but I think with Sibley moving in even
more she's gonna push that way but this
is what we are we are doing now we are
sitting with our legs aren't looking for
tracks staring at the sand hoping for a
little bit of luck
Italian Colombo and Torchwood so no luck
there either there Jamie had the tracks
crossing cheetah Cat Latin this morning
so they are more than likely the fact
that this both Columba and tandi's
tracks their she's obviously got more
than like you got to kill somewhere in
Torchwood and unfortunately we are
unable to traverse and tortured at the
moment because the go almas seems like
they killed a baby hippo not too far to
the east of Sheila cut line it was then
stolen by an Avoca and there's no vocal
mail there with one of them young man
gains feeding and the rest of the pride
lying not too far away oh yeah we have a
Speedy Gonzales pushing us off the red
driving over tracks no doubt if there
are any yes off you go east gate hello I
used to work in London Lizzie it's fixin
James also knows him oh nice to see old
fix what are the best smiles on any
human being I've ever met my life this
is one way to brighten a day just see
fixin and that big toothy grin of his
now as I said someone else you might
remember fixing from London lazy is a
James Henry so let's go all the way back
to the Mara and the north pan and see if
any of them have a wider smile as fixing
dubs
now just in case you're wondering why it
is that we are looking at white pushes
it is unfortunately the only thing the
camera is able to do it's very clever in
many ways and a bit stupid in others and
in this particular way it can only focus
what can only expose for whatever is
closest to the camera because she's
behind the bushes there the camera can
only expose for the bushes in front
that's why she looks dark and it looks
like we look like white bushes so we are
not in infrared she's going to bring the
youngster
George should know the hyenas are not
related to dogs any more than you are
related to baboon which is quite
interesting so that we're all part of
the same order they are part of the
order carnivora like you and I and
baboons are part of the order primates
but tiny separate family dogs and cats
to Mongoose belong to their own family
called the hyena day and that is most
closely related to the her pester day
this is a very suspicious suspicious for
some time keeps looking around so nice
to go foraging with her today so
wonderful to spend some time just
following a hyena through the bush
without it having to disappear will run
away because of course it's open here
Jane very clearly no not all hyenas
Libertad in a lot of activity of a clan
will center on again the mothers that
have youngsters will come to the central
din often if they're very subordinate
they might go and have a demon somewhere
else and the North clan has lots of dens
around this area this just happens to be
the one that is the most active at the
moment and we still think that waffles
as Cubs hostel here and therefore that
waffles are still learning here and
therefore that most of the Cubs that
we've seen over the last few days are
still here as opposed to having been
moved off to another day inside
so this is Ana who we've been watching
the whole time Anatolia nice man that
isn't better than some of the others boy
hyenas have been settled with waffles
for one I don't know Paula when they get
their names I was about to ask our
researchers before we went live but I
don't actually know I think it's
probably once they're about five or six
months old I'm guessing it might know
it's probably before that because Lots
doing childhood their names I'm not sure
I suspect probably actually as soon as
they are playing around outside the game
just listening all the time you won't
find Corky doing this kind of thing up
in that tumor yes you will look around a
bit but not like this there were two
male lions here early this morning there
have been elephants all over the place
so perhaps they're all feeling a little
bit uneasy and as I said if fly-ins or
elephants do come over a place like this
and get upset with the hind as the
adults we'll just vacate they'll abandon
the area until it's safe to come back
sometimes if a Dean is pressured
sufficiently they'll abandon completely
and the Cubs will be left to starve
I don't think that's what's happened
here there is at least one adult Ian
certainly waffles was here earlier today
but Anatolia is not a restful hyena
Zeca largely because we're out at the
wrong time they hunt pretty much
exclusively at night I think or early
morning if you ask Jamie that question
should say that she had most of the
hunting action between I think between
about seven o'clock in the evening 12
o'clock at night and then they had that
one really amazing hippopotamus hunt but
that was kind of unusual and that was a
dawn knows of almost an exceptional
situation
so I think the reason we not see them
hunting is that we know we don't follow
them late at night while we do have
pretty good equipment to look at stuff
at night it's not ideal for hunting
because as we have said to you before
you've got to get pretty close to make
it work and obviously being to close
during hunting it's likely to ruin that
hunt but we have got some pretty amazing
stuff of the hyenas hunting they hunted
that Buffalo that buffalo baby in the de
Prince got that one that was the happy
man so they do hunt in the day but manda
was telling me the general rhythm was to
hang around till about hopple seven
night and then go foraging I don't want
them to do tonight I want her to stay
here and bring her baby out so that we
can see her for our TV show which starts
in about 40 minutes
marcha packet pyjamas it's got some kind
of surprise for us surprise it's a
disappearing warthog bottom I bet that's
exactly what you were expecting and we
mentioned the word surprise trotting off
into the West into the Setting Sun
almost needed a sort of western theme
tune but unfortunately it was gone I
tell you what no never mind I was gonna
say let's sit quietly and watch the
sunset but actually it's not much to
hear except for the wind and the fan
gently cooling our broadcast equipment
and in the distance a red crested Corps
horn and my sudden realization that I've
had my game Drive radio turned down for
at least half an hour no wonder I felt
so peaceful it's actually very pretty
lovely and so the class leaf is just
sort of the right shape for a silhouette
shot nice colors today and clouds that
look like they've sort of flowed through
the sky okay
who doesn't like the clouds okay they
know if we go moving on who doesn't like
the clouds I can't have that let's go
find something else
what can I do give you sunsets don't
like those clouds don't like those Oh
fussy fussy actually I kind of get lose
but I'm a weird cloud and for a week
that is made to be boiling hot there's a
very chilly wind I mean if it brings
more rain that's great if it just brings
cloud and cold weather yeah
who's on the same page as I am that's
why I Lou doesn't like them either if it
just brings cold and cold weather well
then what's the point
spring rain I went to the den by the way
no one's own it's ok we still got an
hour or so no we don't with half an hour
forty minutes we'll see we gambled on
them last week didn't pay off we'll try
again we'll gamble on the most weak I'm
nothing without my hyenas story I don't
even have brains charm
Kirsten says agreed because he if he was
very jobbing yeah run out of words I ate
three cupcakes just before the start of
drive and I was I know I shouldn't have
had three cupcakes it was definitely an
excessive amount of cupcake and now I
think I've just hit a sugar low and I
think that's why my brains scrambling
words it wasn't my most sensible dietary
choice this is why you know you get to
the oh thank you is everyone saying I
have a lot of charm I don't think so
especially not on a sugar low you know
you realize you come to that realization
as an adult that you can buy your own
food and if you want to you can eat
three cupcakes in one sitting and then
you get to the point where you realize
why you weren't allowed to as a child
I put I found a drag mark I didn't find
a drag mark I found a mark of an
elephant moving a stick across the road
I'll show you what I mean I got so
excited for one second I thought perhaps
we'd found the mystery of the
disappearing team Ghana but I haven't
all I can see is elephant tracks and
then yeah no that is not a drag mark one
big fundamental difference that is
pretty entertaining is that it's a drag
mark she really looks a bit flatter and
wider all right speaking of an animal
that might leave a drag mark after
hunting let's go across to Sydney and
husana asana is now is starting to
become active and I cannot see what is
thinking about to do at the moment as
there is no pretty animals year where we
are nothing is exciting him he might
wake up and go to somewhere else look at
that I've just said it now that he is
now about you taking action so let's
hope it's not going to get disappear
deep in the thick bushes we still want
to be with him
maybe it's just now trying to come up
out of the to the open space but looking
at what he's doing now when the head is
raised by the air and the wind direction
is coming from that side he might be
fascinated by the Sun by something is
getting from the air particles so I am
NOT going to leave him I'm going to
follow him until I see what thinking
he's now again heading towards the
waterhole maybe he's going to drink
again or he might be going to
investigate for something he has been
eating for the few couple of days but
that is not gonna stop him hunt from
hunting
one of my guests our beard he's giving a
very good comment on husana he met was
analyzed before so this cat is going
back to the waterhole now and after
drinking it might look bigger again so
I'm just going to again drive back to
the waterhole and enjoy seeing him
drinking it's always lovely to see this
kind of casual drinking last time he was
here a few just about I can see it's not
even in power few minutes ago he was
here and he had a lot of what now he's
back again you can see that for the past
two days he did he did not have any
moisture so the caucus were already old
which is something maybe which made he
able to come and drink quite a lot of
water like now so he is quenching his
thirst at the moment
so don't get surprised here when hearing
the engines and the camera clicking I am
not alone at the moment and deciding
there are some other guests as well
enjoying the same sighting as me so this
animals mostly when they're Democratic
territories they also consider what
availability and food availability but
this one is not yet responsible of any
of the territories in the area I have
seen him Democrat in the territory but I
don't know if he knows very well the
interpretation of marking the territory
because sometimes he does leave his
scent on top of his father sent the
father is not worried at the moment
about those kind of marking on top of
his scent marks
so you can see that the tongue doesn't
really collect quite a lot of water so
now let's cross over to the Maasai Mara
in Kenya where James is having one of
those animals who are sometimes giving
Hassan a tough time and I know that's a
very dark picture of the hyena she
suddenly ran off so we tried to go back
towards waffles then didn't see anything
then she came back here we're in pretty
much the same position we was when you
last saw us
now I know that's not great fungi sorry
about that
she's gonna scan the spotlight if
there's anything else there's nothing
further
I know it's a very dark image don't
worry about it there's not much we can
do
we'll improve it I hope by the time our
TV show comes about top four seven at
least you can see the reflection of the
eyes
she's so up and down and so kind of just
uncomfortable you know Gina these
infrared eyes make a beautiful kind of
cartoon terror eyes if you like in furry
that's great like that you can see those
eyes shining now I really hope that the
other adults are going to pop back here
at some stage this evening now remember
we do have our TV show so we are going
to shut down in half an hour you can't
actually catch it on youtube if you want
tomorrow
of course returns know pretty much to
normal but tomorrow night is safari
lives episode two must be 25 or 24
all right all we're gonna watch and see
what happens here I have something
exciting happens in the next little
while in the meantime I'm going to say
goodbye to you I'm going to thank you
very much for contributing to the show
with your questions and your comments
and I will see you tomorrow morning if
not on the TV